hablamos un poco más en profundidad
acerca de cómo se replica el adn y vamos
a hablar acerca de los actores que
participan en este proceso y cuando
hable acerca de esto voy a mencionar
mucho los extremos 3 prima y 5 prima de
la molécula de adn y si eso es
completamente desconocido para ti te
invito a ver el vídeo de la estructura
anti paralela del adn y vamos a ver un
repaso rápido solo en caso de que ya
hayas visto esto pero no recuerdes
algunos detalles
este es un acercamiento a la molécula de
adn en realidad esta imagen es del vídeo
que les acabo de mencionar y cuando
hablamos de los extremos 5 prima y 3
prima nos estamos refiriendo a lo que
sucede en las rosas que forman esta
parte del esqueleto de azúcar fosfato
así que tenemos ribosa por aquí que es
un azúcar de 5 carbonos y podemos
numerar los átomos de carbono
este es el carbono una prima el carbono
2 prima el carbono 3 prima el carbono 4
prima y el carbono 5 prima así que este
lado de la escalera se podría decir va
en dirección 3 prima a 5 prima éste es
el extremo 3 prima y este es el extremo
5 prima y observa que este fosfato está
unido al carbono 3 primas luego vamos al
carbono 5 prima que se encuentra unido a
un fosfato el cual está unido a un
carbono 3 prima luego vamos al carbono 5
prima que está unido a un fosfato
ahora vamos a este otro lado y como ya
hemos visto la estructura es anti
paralela lo que quiere decir que es
paralela pero ambos lados están
orientados en sentidos opuestos así que
este es el carbono 3 prima
este es el carbono 5 prima
este es el carbono 3 prima y este es el
carbono 5 prima así que esto es justo a
lo que nos referimos cuando decimos que
la estructura es anti paralela estas dos
cadenas o hebras principales
estas dos cadenas son paralelas entre sí
pero están orientadas en direcciones
opuestas así que este es el extremo 3
prima y este es el extremo 5 prima y
esto va a ser realmente importante para
que comprendan la replicación debido a
que la adn polimerasa la enzima que está
añadiendo más y más nucleótidos para
elongar la cadena de adn sólo puede
agregar nucleótidos en el extremo 3
prima así que aquí sólo sería capaz de
añadir nucleótidos en este sentido no
sería capaz de añadir nucleótidos en
este sentido así que una manera de
pensar en ello es que sólo puede añadir
nucleótidos en el extremo 3
o solo poder lograr la cadena de adn
yendo de 5 prima
3 prima
si solo se puede añadir nucleótidos en
el extremo 3 prima entonces se tiene que
ir de 5 prima a 3 prima no se puede ir
de 3 prima a 5 prima no se puede seguir
añadiendo nucleótidos en el extremo 5
prima usando la adn polimerasa y a qué
me refiero cuando hablo de la polimerasa
bueno vamos a ver este diagrama por aquí
que realmente nos da una visión general
de todos los diferentes actores aquí
está nuestra cadena de adn y podríamos
decir que se encuentra en su forma
natural no replicada y se puede ver que
aquí están los extremos 3 prima y 5
prima y podríamos seguir una de estas
hebras si empezamos que en este extremo
3 prima y lo seguimos todo el camino
hasta aquí vemos que este es el extremo
5 prima correspondiente por lo que esta
y ésta son la misma cadena y este si lo
seguimos todo el camino hasta aquí vemos
que está
es la misma hebra así que este es el
extremo 3 prima y este es el extremo 5
prima de la misma hebra ahora la idea
general y hemos hablado de esto en
vídeos anteriores donde damos una visión
general de la replicación la idea
general es que la doble hélice tiene que
ser dividida y entonces podemos
construir el otro lado de la escalera de
cada una de estas dos hebras separadas
podríamos ver esto como si se tratara de
un cierre de un pantalón o una chamarra
que abrimos y luego le ponemos nuevos
cierres a cada lado aunque en realidad
todo esto es mucho más complejo que
simplemente decir oh vamos a abrir el
cierre y poner nuevos cierres a cada
lado esto involucra un montón de enzimas
y todo tipo de cosas e incluso en este
diagrama no estamos mostrando todos los
actores que participan en este proceso
estamos mostrando los actores
principales los que podrías ver o
escuchar en una discusión cuando la
gente habla acerca de la replicación del
adn
así que por aquí todo se encuentra
enrollado déjame escribir eso
lladó
y resulta que conforme se desenrolla una
hebra la otra hebra se enrolla cada vez
más así que para poder separar las
cadenas necesitamos tener una enzima que
nos ayude a desenrollar esta hélice y
esa enzima es la topoisomerasa y la
forma en que funciona es que rompe
partes del esqueleto de manera temporal
para que se pueda desenrollar y luego se
vuelvan a unir pero la idea general es
que desenrolla la cadena para que la
enzima del icaza pueda empezar a actuar
y la el ica sea realmente no se parece a
este pequeño triángulo que está cortando
cosas si pudiéramos ver la estructura
molecular de la él y casa probablemente
te parecería que es mucho más fascinante
pero lo que está haciendo la él y casa
es romper los enlaces de hidrógeno entre
las bases nitrogenadas en este caso
tenemos una adenina aquí y una timina y
rompería estos enlaces de hidrógeno
entre estas dos bases así que primero
laptop o isomerasa desenrolla la
molécula y a continuación la l
separar las cadenas y pensamos en estas
dos cadenas de manera diferente ya que
como he mencionado sólo se puede añadir
nucleótidos yendo del extremo 5 prima al
extremo 3 prima por lo que esta cadena
de abajo a la que llamaremos nuestra
cadena adelantada está en realidad lo
tiene bastante sencillo recuerda que
este es el extremo 5 prima por lo que
puede añadir nucleótidos en esa
dirección yendo de 5 prima a 3 prima y
lo que tiene que ocurrir aquí para
iniciar el proceso es que se necesita un
cebador de arn y el personaje que
sintetiza el cebador de adn es la adn
pri masa
y vamos a hablar un poco más acerca de
estos actores cuando lleguemos a ver la
cadena rezagada pero van a añadir un
salvador de arn y una vez que hay un
cebador la adn polimerasa simplemente
puede empezar a añadir nucleótidos puede
empezar a añadir los nucleótidos en el
extremo 3 prima y la razón por la cual
este proceso es más sencillo o más
directo en la cadena adelantada es
debido a que la adn polimerasa por aquí
y una vez más no son estos rectángulos
perfectos como se muestra en este
diagrama en realidad son moléculas mucho
más fascinantes que eso hay una adn
polimerasa allá arriba y también hay una
aquí abajo
bolt y verás a esa polimerasa podemos
pensar que va siguiendo el cierre
abierto y simplemente va añadiendo
nucleótidos en el extremo 3 prima y así
de este lado esto parece ser bastante
directo y podrías decir que no sería más
sencillo si pudiéramos añadir
nucleótidos en el extremo 5 prima porque
entonces podríamos decir que esto podría
ir de 3 primas a 5 prima así que tal vez
la polimerasa o una polimerasa diferente
podría simplemente seguir añadiendo
nucleótidos de esa manera y entonces
todo sería sencillo pues bien resulta
que ese no es el caso no se puede añadir
nucleótidos en el extremo 5 prima y
permítanme ser clara este 3 prima se
refiere a esta cadena y en esta cadena
de aquí este es el extremo 3 prima y
este es el extremo 5 prima no se puede
simplemente seguir añadiendo nucleótidos
solo así
así que cómo es que la biología resuelve
esto pues lo resuelve añadiéndose
valores conforme se separan las cadenas
va añadiendo cebadores y este diagrama
muestra el cebador como un solo
nucleótido pero un salvador está
conformado típicamente por varios
nucleótidos aproximadamente 10
nucleótidos así que va a añadir
aproximadamente 10 nucleótidos de arne
por aquí y eso lo hace la adn pri masa
por lo que la adn pri masa va a lo largo
de la cadena superior y está añadiendo
el cebador de arn que no es sólo un
nucleótido tiende a estar conformado por
varios nucleótidos y una vez que se
tiene el cebador de arn entonces la
polimerasa puede añadir nucleótidos en
dirección 5 prima a 3 prima los puede
añadir en el extremo 3 prima puede
empezar a añadir nucleótidos de esa
manera
así que entre los actores tenemos a la
primas a que añade un cebador aquí y
luego se inicia la elongación de 5 prima
a 3 prima se inicia la elongación de esa
manera y luego se salta un tramo y esto
vuelve a suceder así que terminas con
todos estos fragmentos de adn y estos
fragmentos son llamados fragmentos de
okazaki y por qué se le llama cadena
rezagada se le llama así debido a que el
proceso se tiene que hacer de una manera
que se siente como poco óptima donde
tienes que ir creando estos fragmentos
de hojas aquí mientras se sigue esta
apertura por lo que es un proceso más
lento y luego todos estos fragmentos se
pueden unir usando la adn ligas a no
sólo se vuelven a unir las cadenas sino
que el arnés se sustituye con adn y
luego cuando todo está listo tenemos una
cadena de adn que se está replicando así
que cuando todo esto concluye vamos a
tener dos cadenas dobles
una aquí de la cadena rezagada y otra
aquí abajo de la cadena adelantada